we got to be able to say that's a spicy
meatball let's do a
teaspoon oh y everyone is starting to
see I might just this super quick let's
go this is really
spicy oh
my roll hey guys on this episode of heat
eaters we're going full Italiano and I
know that normally you don't think spicy
when you think Italian food but there
are some great dishes to try spicy
Italian is more than just adding crushed
red chili flakes on top of pizza or
pasta you can go really deep and there's
some really spicy Regional Italian food
you think calabrian chilies which is
actually pretty spicy I'm here in the
Bronx on Arthur Avenue the mecca of
Italian food and meeting up with my
friend Chef Christian Patron who is
raised here he literally knows with
everyone on the Block he's going to take
me to a couple legendary spots to try
some Italian Specialties including spicy
sausages from collabria pork store and a
proetta sandwich I've had my eye on from
Mike's Deli after our food craw I'm
going to meet up with none other than
babish to cook an epic Italian meal
featuring a pasta dish that's so
spicy it's called assassin's pasta and
this Assassin's pasta might just kill
Bill
[Music]
Christian yes you made it oh my God I'm
so happy what's up how's it going so
good so much better out of you here okay
first of all all I can smell is cured
meat oh this oh yeah get ready then my
friend this store behind me was started
by my friend Pete's dad came here from
Calabria and all he knew was one thing
how to make cured meats this type of
place doesn't exist anymore will never
exist again we need to show the
world the famous sausage chandelier hey
hey how are you welcome to Calabria po
what's up do how you doing hello Hi how
are this is my friend a hi nice to meet
you I heard you put some treats out for
us I did oh my God I got some
and andu it's a cab calabra it's a calab
we went to calabia itself to get the
ingredient this is a spreadable
spreadable sausage everything is hot
overhead then I have a extra hot supera
hot sausage soad it's age for 7 weeks 7
weeks okay so you're moving it sausage
uhuh yeah we got dates on those things
okay sa it's age for 5 weeks Andia it's
age for a whole month oh really it's
very soft very soft wouldn't you say
that the cab appreciate spice and heat
possibly more than any other region oh
they like hot stuff you guys if you like
to try some yeah hold on here come on
Bill I this is the I got you there go
flat one yeah that has a good kick this
is the extra hot a good kick these are
the extra hot oh the are the extra hot
what kind of chilies do you use for your
all the hot stuff I love your chili yeah
this and you you like
you so delicious I love the texture and
the spice is actually pretty strong in
that it's it's definitely got a lot of
flavor like I said I can just imagine
that in a meatball how do you get that
texture though yeah like are you just
casing it and he's not going to tell you
yeah and you know what surpris me you
said it's age for a month it's that
aging that makes it taste so good I'm a
firm believer that the air itself in
Calabria pork store is one of the main
factors of the way that the this sausage
cures so I would love to uja and um you
you said you have spicy
Panetta that in my meatball is going to
be awesome oh God yeah how old is that
night that's beautiful been here for a
few weeks that i' been here for a few
weeks is the best um you are an absolute
angel thank you love you brother thank
you so much so nice to meet you nice to
meet you I hold thank you yes please bye
guys hey such a gentleman I love you you
guys are going to eat something oh
they're going to eat it they're going to
eat it please help yourself
guys so this is what I was talking about
this is the Arthur Avenue Retail Market
1940 my boy David Greco his dad Mike
started Mike's Deli legendary and that's
who we're going to go see right now
you're going to love this guy come
[Music]
on Mr what are you doing kid what's up
bua I brought a real special VIP famous
One my kids love that stuff she likes it
spicy like us calab of people absolute
Legend absolute Legend So This is my
dear friend David I mean he holds rain
here at the Arthur Avenue Retail Market
absolutely legendary I've known him
since I was this tall I used to feed him
a slice of M he used to be so happy our
spicy subas we do that that's just a
pick on a lot of regions in Italy don't
embrace the spice as much as but
specifically Calabria and I grew up in
ponza a little island like uh off the
coast of Naples between Rome and Naples
a little pepperino you know like spice
wasn't a big part of our upbring
Calabria it's about how hot can you
handle it really they love it [__] in
Calabria I know what I want very simple
classic potato and egg sandwich potato
and egg sandwich would do for us spicy
we do a long hot fried and we do it with
a top with that La bamb calaba I know
you were excited about something the
pora I I mean I'm a that's real calab so
you're going to do extra spicy calab
bomb on top yes I heard you beat Bobby
fle yeah he's all right Bobby for an
Irish guy he's okay with us we call him
Bob around here in the Bronx so you and
I have something in common we both Beat
Bobby F nice nice oh know oh all right
oh did you no I lost it's a long story I
want to rematch Bob love relax Chef
thank you so much oh pleasure
pleasure what was it like growing up
like as an Italian
American in this neighborhood Christian
you know like everyone in here it's like
this is like the epicenter of my life
right this place like specifically this
Market that we're in right now was put
here in the' 40s uhhuh because so many
immigrants from Italy had set up around
World War I they were they were getting
out of Dodge right Arthur R was just
inundated with push cards sing meat
oysters dry goods and what they did was
built places like the retail Market they
brought all the vendors inside I'm crazy
history have you had K
before sandwich coming right up Keith
how are you brother so Koto is an
acquired taste it's made from a very
specific type of bitter orange and it's
an Italian soda Italian soft drink yummy
absolutely nothing better to uh to wash
down a Spicy sandwich I know right
it it tastes like AI this is the poretta
oh my God look at this wait wait
where we got to add a little white
truffle to this sandwich because we've
upgraded him you I know I brought a VIP
I never get I never got white truffles
on my potato and egg now this porett is
the bomb is the spread on the bottom and
top then it's finished with the smoked
mozzarella there two types of pepper in
the middle one is a jalapeno and one is
the c bra pepper sliced and diced
pickled garlic and the spicy calabra
oil oh
[Music]
man that doesn't make you want to be a
better person wow that pork is insane oh
my God that's the calor recipe this is
spicy this is spicy and it comes up on
you you know it's probably the spiciest
like Italian thing that I've had hold on
a
second I'm starting it fits over here a
little bit listen a potato and egg
sandwich is essentially a fatata between
two pieces of bread I used to get it
with some vinegar Peppers but with these
kabian chilies man and his stuff yeah
like it's like right there and right
there yeah and like the pora sandwich he
put pickle chilies the calabrian the
jalapeno and then there's chili oil and
you see like it soaked it and soaked
saturated fully saturated into the bread
and I love that the bread holds up to it
it's something that I'm going to crave
all the time you might as well be on a
street corner in Rome having a shave
poretta sandwich right very very good
very all righty
guys stop fresh should have got through
mix with a little regular canoli cream
uhhuh and then we add the cayenne and
then we add the calibra chili Salud guys
enjoy y dude I got all day bro it's so
spicy oh yeah it's got some spicy it's
spicy yeah it's got bite a spicy dessert
who would chefs it was a pleasure thank
you so much this was such a special
experience seriously sorry Christian but
I'm going straight to the source you're
going to be seeing me here a lot I'm
here anytime you need if I'm not here my
guys are here but I I always call you
when I'm here I'm like I'm going I tell
you nothing makes me more more happy or
proud than to be able to literally show
the world how I grew up the people I
grew up around and the food that
inspires me every day and be a part of
this is an honor so very grateful thank
you all right just left Arthur Avenue
and now we're heading to babish's place
to make an epic spicy
meal come in what's up Angy what's up
how are you you found the
getting prepared we got to look crispy
if we're going to be sweating looking
horrible with the hot style what's going
on thanks for having me thanks for being
here all right so what are we doing
today I brought you some goodies um
we're going to make an Italian delicious
spicy Italian meal oh right I hope
there's a spicy meatball oh come on
you're like the meatball guy okay am I a
meatball I don't know that's a good
reputation so we have Uya Uya so we put
that in the meatballs we're going to put
that in the meatball so I thought that
that would be really fun to do Panetta
that they also cure inh house and it has
some like spicy chilies on it which is
like awesome all right calabrian chilies
with little fish yeah this is about as
spicy as Italian food gets right now it
smells so good it tastes so good I love
the addition of the like the fish sauce
by makes it more Mommy that way you
don't have to use anies although I
brought an chovies anyway because
they're in chili oil in chili oil in
chili oil I've never seen such I have um
from smoking ETS Farm oh
boy Carolina Reapers Reapers okay
they're Reapers I don't even want to
touch
iten crossbows this the Scorpion Pepper
powder okay I'm not going to sniff that
don't and this in the air it's insane if
we're going to
[Music]
spicifer do best which is bastard
Italian cuisine let's give it a shot so
to prepare with your spicy meatballs I
think we should make spaghetti alasa ooh
nailed it first dry alasa I got it okay
so it's assassin's pasta so the story be
the pasta is this cook and Bari uh was
distracted by this beautiful woman so he
added way too many chilies burned the
pasta and then to save it he had to add
tomato water and cook the pasta in the
pan sounds like a bad cook it was way
too spicy obviously because he added too
many chilies and the guest was like what
are you trying to do you're trying to
kill me and therefore the Assassin pasta
was born if this took place in Italy I
bet it was not that spicy I know right
it was just like little Ting like M but
we're going to make it spicy and we're
going to try to kill Bill well you
brought all the evil stuff from from
smoking editings so yeah we're going to
make this properly spicy I think so like
proper spicy like real spicy I think we
should start on the meatballs let's
start on the meatballs yeah I know that
you have a really beautiful meatball
recipe I designed these to try to be as
juicy as possible by adding as much fat
as possible so nuts uh egg yolks in
particular first I'm making the panad to
that I'm going to add buttermilk and
then for an extra hit of fat we got an
amount of heavy cream this basically has
to be a paste pine nuts pine nuts I love
that cuz pine nuts have a lot of fat as
well exactly and it's very Sicilian we
got to process together our herbs and
which is oregano and fennel petta
parsley the garlic I'm just going to add
everything why not all right so pine
nuts go in one whole uja into the mix we
got some sauteed onions here okay
exactly let's get one of
these let's add that add the
panad yes let zest some lemon in there
we need an egg and an egg yolk normally
you just add one egg for this amount of
meat but the egg yolk is of course going
to bring more fat parmesan and peino yep
and the most important thing oh duh all
right how much do we add of this we got
to be able to say that's a spicy let do
let's do a teaspoon I feel like let's
start there and then kind of feel it out
does look and smell angry we are trying
to kill Bill he's shaking his head right
now all right so normally I'd go full
and get my hands up in this but I need
to preserve my hands and my
genitals you want to be able to go to
the bathroom after yes yes I mean it's
one of my favorite things to do what do
you think perfect I think it's right
where it needs to
be for the theme of what we're what
we're doing today any Li oh my God wait
I just got some on my thumb and my thumb
is start is starting to burn oh sorry
Bill we're making balls and Searing them
I can see the evil red oil leaching out
of oh my God you do you do see it oh my
God it smells so
good okay it's starting to
happen careful look at all that chili
oil how gorgeous is that beautiful and
we can just let
that rock for a little bit to let those
firm up and now for the pasta now for
the pasta yeah spaghetti mhm and then
garlic they use dry chilies in this
recipe uh normally but I think that we
should use like the
the um calabrian with the little fish
with the little fish that's going to be
so good so good I have this big bowl of
Reapers let's add how but we add this
little guy I'm just going to paste this
up so it's not like big chunks in there
it's more integrated into you for that
and then we have tomato paste and some
pada and I think we can add it to a pot
of boiling water so it's like a tomato
paste water add the garlic chilies the
calabrian chilies you kind of I think
what they do is it's just just like
leave it in like that and let it burn
and get crusty on the
bottom try not to cough on my hands keep
the food safe oh y everyone is to see I
might just this super quick oh yeah okay
come on guys I'm over the stove it's
totally fine yeah tough
up oh there we go
yeah yeah let's do it oh yeah see and
then you just start doing
this very interesting right wow that's
drank that up really fast yeah very fast
so I'm just going to keep going with it
yeah I'll say it again it it it's insane
to me that this came out of Italy this
is like the most anti- Italian method
I've ever seen
that there we
go things over one bow I think what am I
thinking it comes in a pair it's
spaghetti and meat balls not spaghetti
in meatball oh I get it balls balls it's
a beautiful that'll help with the spice
oh I love how the meatball just like
that's a bite super tender oh yeah you
got it
all oh it's really
good it's really
good it's
spicy it's very spicy definitely but
it's more like the punch of the chili
flavor like the calaban chili mixed with
the reaper and like the ghost pepper
powdered like you get all of the chili
elements in different dimension yeah and
it's not that bright fresh sort of taste
that you get with with Scotch bonnet or
stuff like that sometimes it's the
deeper like cooked yeah yeah something
really good it's really good I'm
genuinely surprised when I saw you
burning that
pasta that was fre you out I don't know
about this but that is genuinely killer
I see why it's gone all viral mhm having
it be like a little panicky spicy is
actually really great and it it lives up
to its name it's assassin's pasta okay
now it's time to Kill Bill what do you
think let's murder bill
first
bill I hope they pay you extra for this
I'm not looking I'm not looking I'm not
looking don't look if I don't look it's
not happening the amount of gasps that
I'm hearing right now make me think I
should stop yeah it's okay it's a season
CU he he he spread it so are you excited
I it looks delicious I'm just going to
go in I'm just going to go
in Big B do it do it do it do it do
it that was m
mistake he just made a
mistake it's fine it's fine it's fine
yeah it's
fine um this is a really good
meatball it's delicious right um I got
to say what does this work wait here
I'll in the words of Elton John I'm
Still
Standing
I think not I'm scared when you wait
yeah that spicy that came on faster
though now I'm regretting that okay okay
you win all right it's spicy [__] he's
alive oh God it's just building
yeah well Bill you know it's because we
love you Season Two Season Two we need
you around for season 3 actually kill
you call me in 3 hours you know it's
it's building tolerance
when you hang with me that's what
happens your tolerance gets built heat
eaters yes Andrew you killed it thank
you for having me on and it's season 3
next mon yes and what you got going on
in the Horizon um my cookbooks out right
now basic with babish then bakes with
babish and uh the the bed and babish is
coming out soon reservations coming for
that bed and babish is is the is the
Airbnb so wrap you guys thank
you J
so the finale that I'm going to bring
you on food that you have to try it's
been a biggest seller here we call this
Italian nachos because it's made with
truffle oil balsamic the chilies all the
peppers that we love and we add paja to
it and gr chees there a parm chunks of
par in
there wo that was kind of
[Music]
spicy hey guys it's Esther from heat
eaters thanks for watching please like
And subscribe and for more episodes
click here